it's just one of those iconic weapons
you know that when you have it in your
hand or something very special about
that moment and they really really lean
into that with this game and so one of
the very first things you can do with a
lightsaber is that you can deflect back
the Stormtrooper blast and it just feels
so good there's no like on-screen
indicator there's not a big prompt over
your head that flashes and said now is
when you need to block you have to
actually watch the Stormtrooper look
ahead wait for their incoming shot and
then quickly deflect now if you just
hold it down you'll be able to deflect
everything no problem until your stamina
wears down but it's not going to do any
damage to them it's just a flex back
however if you time it just right it
will actually deflect it right back at
them for an instant k